how much football do you watch a week I
watch I watched two games on Sunday I
taped three right then I watched a
Monday game and then Tuesday I watched
one of the three that I taped Wednesday
I watched another one then I watched the
Thursday night game and then Friday
I got watch the Sunday night game
Saturday I watch college football okay
and it's fine okay so I have a simple
male brain they could just sit there and
just just enjoy it I can just enjoy it
so so does your wife watch any of these
games with you does she know she has the
female complex multitasking prank that's
why they can't be happy they did just
they just always they're like what is
that lizard that can look at two things
at once that's what they like so they
got the shoes they want and then they
see some other women walking a dog look
at Skinny [ __ ] over here she thinks
she's cute right I think that's what
I've learned Oh God what makes women
happy nothing and that is why they have
slowly taken over the NFL because it
ignores them that that we can just sit
there with like the pizza and the drink
that's not holiday just be like enjoy
yourself so you're saying that yet
because you're happy that you think your
wife and women in general it's a jealous
of it they're jealous how simple the
male brain is that you can just sit
there and be entertained and fight true
happiness and it just bugs them so they
gotta ruin it why it's slowly taking
over the NFL you know all next month
once again they're gonna dress everybody
in the NFL like newborn baby girls for
whatever reason did you forget that this
breast cancer yeah oh here we go
yes so they did it last year they're
gonna do it again this year yes they can
slowly gonna take it over and they get
they're gonna they're gonna move
yourself cuz I'm telling you I don't
understand why they keep trying to go
into a male football league it's like
why don't you guys band together and
start your own league get your own thing
going but I realize they don't want
their own thing they don't want their
own [ __ ] they want our [ __ ]
what is and it's I think it's because
we're happy we're just sitting there
enjoying ourselves having a good time
without them it drives them nuts
and they've just got to go in there and
ruin it so they don't like they got
women's basketball they don't even like
it
they don't even like they don't even
like football guy don't get it I don't
get like the fascination like if my wife
is having like three of her friends over
I screw I leave I don't need to be there
and ruin it for I know you guys I'm
gonna change the dynamic cuz I'm there
and you can't talk about a hundred
percent female stuff out of courtesy I'm
gonna get out of it I'm gonna leave but
they can't do that you're saying
one guy one chauvinistic all right now
you know whatever I'll tell that story
better next time I'm going to get it
right
[Applause]
you